عاش حياته داخل فقاعه بلاستيكيه دون ان
يقترب منه احد لم يلمسه بشر على الاطلاق
حتى والدته كانت تتواصل معه من وراء هذا
الغلاف البلاستيكي وهذه القبله كانت
بمشاعر مغلفه بمراره الفقد في اي لحظه
ديفيدار طفل الفقاعه النادر
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
عم 71 ولد طفل الفقاعه ديفيدار الذي عانى
طيله سنوات حياته من مرض النذر يدعى نقص
المناعه المشترك وهو مجموعه من الاضطرابات
النادره التي تسببها طفرات في جينات
مختلفه تشارك في تطوير وظيفه الخلايا
المناعيه المكافحه للعدوى وهو مرض يصيب
الاطفال الرضع بصوره نادره وتصاحبه اعراض
مرضيه اخرى في ذلك الحين كان المصاب بهذا
المرض فاقدا لاي امل في البقاء ولدا ديفيد
كان انجب طفلا قبله بسنوات وكان مصابا
بالمرض نفسه وتوفي بعد مرور سته اشهر
الاطباء واخبروا الوالدين ان طفلهما
القادم ربما سيكون مثل اخيه ولد ديفيد
فيتاره ولم يكن هناك تفاؤل بشان بقائه على
قيد الحياه لذا عند لحظه ولادته تم تنظيف
غرفه المستشفى وتعقيمها مرات عده لجعلها
خاليه من الجراثيم قدر الامكان وبمجرد
خروجه من رحم امه كانت غرفته المصممه
خصيصا له جاهزه فوضع ديفيد في بيئه معقمه
للغايه
لاحقا اقترح الاطباء وضع ديفيد في هذه
الفقاعه البلاستيكيه لحمايته من الجراثيم
والعدوى على امل علاجه بزراعه نخاع العظم
من شقيقته الكبرى ولكن بعد ان يكبر قليلا
في العمر
اي شيء كان يحصل عليه داخل فقاعته كان يجب
ان يكون معقما 100% ويتم ادخاله من فتحه
خاصه خيارات ديفيد في الطعام كانت محدوده
بالمعلبات والطعام المجفف المعقم
عند بلوغ ديفيد عمره ثلاث سنوات صممت له
فقاعه اخرى اكبر في بيت والده وذهب للعيش
داخل منزله بشكل كامل وحين بلوغه السابعه
عرفت وسائل اعلام بقصته عندما انتشرت
اخبار ديفيد تواصل معه كبار الاطباء
لمحاوله علاجه كما وصل نبا حالاته الى
وكاله ناسا للفضاء فصممت له هذه البدله
العازله ليستطيع ديفيد ارتدائها والخروج
لدقائق خارج المنزل استخدم ديفيد تلك
البدله سبع مرات فقط طوال حياته لانها
كانت تحتاج وقتا طويلا من التحضير كما ان
عائلته لم ترغب بالمخاطره
صدمه كبرى تلقتها اسره ديفيد عند علمهم ان
انسجه شقيقته ليست مطابقه او مناسبه
لعمليه الزراعه والعلاج الجميع ظن ان هذه
الفقاعه ستكون حياه ديفيد الدائمه لكن
اسره ديفيد ارادت له العيش مثل بقيه
الاطفال الاصحاء فقررت اجراء عمليه له
اخبرنا الاطباء ان نسبه نجاح العمليه كانت
مرتفعه وقالوا انها ربما تنجح وربما لا
ولكن اذا لم تنجح فسنرجع ببساطه الى ما
نحن عليه الان
لم تنجح العمليه وخرج ديفيد من غرفه
العمليات بين الحياه والموت نظرت اليه امه
ولاول مره سمعت صوته ولمست شعر راسه في 22
من فبراير عام 84 اغمض ديفيد عينيه ودخل
في غيبوبه خلعت والدته قناعها وقبلت طفلها
لاول مره ثم مات ديفيد طفل الفقعه لكن
قصته الهمت العالم فالاطباء استخدموا
الدراسات على خلايا ديفيد لمنح من يعانون
من حالته نفسها الامل بالحياه ببعض
الادويه دون اللجوء للعيش في فقاعه مثل
فقاعات ديفيد
[موسيقى]